[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Wir haben gerade November.
Das sage ich, weil ich weiß,
dass wir das Video erst später ausstrahlen werden,
nämlich im neuen Jahr.
Und wir haben noch Weihnachtsdeko.
Aber das Video ist super wichtig, denn morgen, am 14. November,
wird Samira 10 Jahre alt.
Schon 10 - ich kann es nicht glauben!
Mein großes Baby wird 10.
Es ist irgendwie so jedes Jahr und dann zweistellig.
Ist noch einmal so ein Signal an die Mama:
Ich werde groß.
Und ja, dieses Jahr ist es natürlich leider so,
dass keine große Party gefeiert wird,
sondern wir bleiben wirklich nur unter uns,
also wir zu viert: Samira, Murat, Ela, ich.
Natürlich gibt's trotzdem eine schöne Torte.
Samira liebt Donuts und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht,
mache ich einen Drip Cake mit Donuts drauf.
Ich glaube, darüber wird sie sich sehr freuen.
Dann gibt's morgen, am Samstag,
einfach die Überraschung zu Hause.
Vielleicht schaffe ich es ja auch,
ein bisschen was mit meinem Handy zu filmen
und werde meiner kleinen großen Maus trotzdem.
eine Überraschung vorbereiten.
Was ich jetzt hier machen werde, ist Folgendes:
Ich habe meinen Mantelrührölteig, den es schon als Basic-Rezept gibt.
Ich zeige euch hier die Zutaten.
Ich mache jetzt die doppelte Menge,
denn die Torte soll im Durchmesser 20 cm klein oder groß sein,
eher eine höhere Torte und habe hier deswegen die Menge für zwei Böden,
die ich auch gleichzeitig backen werde,
und werde das Ganze mit Konfettistreusel zubereiten.
Von der Anleitung her könnte gerne im Basic-Rezept nachschauen.
Ich nehme jetzt dafür 6 Eier (zimmerwarm), 150 g Zucker,
eine Prise Salz, etwas Tonka Wonka für den Geschmack,
jeweils 300 g Mineralwasser oder Buttermilch und Sonnenblumenöl,
450 g Mehl, 200 g Mandeln
- die sind bereits geschält und werden gleich gemahlen -
1 Päckchen Backpulver (= 3 TL) und 100 g Konfettistreusel.
Hier habe ich einfach die halbe Zuckermenge.
Ich nehme also den Basic-Teig mit reduzierter Zucker Menge,
denn die Torte wird so schon süß genug
und dann passt es, denke ich, direkt,
denn das Konfetti sind auch gesüßt. Dann ist die Torte nicht zu süß.
Zuerst nehmt ihr die Eier mit dem Zucker, Salz und Tonka Wonka.
Statt Tonka Wonka könnt ihr auch eine Tonkabohne einfach dazu reiben,
eine kleine Prise.
Die Zutaten werden jetzt schön cremig verrührt.
Das dauert ungefähr 10-15 Min.
In der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon einmal die Mandeln fein mahlen
und das Backpulver mit dem Mehl vermischen.
Jetzt kommen noch die beiden Flüssigkeiten vorsichtig zum Teig
und werden ganz kurz eingerührt
und anschließend folgen schon die trockenen Zutaten,
die ich ganz kurz mit dem Schneebesen unterrühre.
Ich möchte eher eine kleinere, hohe Torte haben.
Deswegen bereite ich schon die 2 Backringe mit 18 cm Durchmesser vor.
Jetzt könnt ihr noch die Konfettistreusel dazugeben
und den fertigen Teig in die 2 vorbereiteten Backringe füllen.
Die hab ich jetzt hier mit Backpapier umschlagen,
weil der Teig doch relativ flüssig ist.
Ihr seht schon, das ist recht viel Teig.
Deswegen streiche ich den jetzt hier noch am Rand hoch,
damit er schön gleichmäßig backt und in der Mitte nicht reißt.
Jetzt kann ich beide Teige backen
und dann schon direkt die Donuts vorbereiten.
[Musik]
[Uhr]
Die Donuts werden jetzt nicht wie auf meinem Kanal
aus Hefeteig gemacht und frittiert.
Ich mache es mir jetzt ein bisschen einfacher,
weil ich denke, dass diese Donuts richtig cool auf der Torte aussehen.
Ich nehme einfach so eine Donut-Backform
und mache einen kleinen Rührteig, also wie bei Muffins.
Dafür nehme ich 150 g Zucker, etwas Salz, 200 g Mehl
und 1 TL Backpulver, 2 Eier, Vanilleextrakt
und jeweils ungefähr 100 ml Sonnenblumenöl und Olivenöl.
Nein, Orangensaft!
Danke. Orangensaft!
Vielleicht brauche ich es nicht komplett.
Es kommt immer drauf an, wie groß die Eier sind.
Dafür braucht ihr auch wirklich gar kein Handrührgerät,
sondern ihr verrührt die trockenen Zutaten in einer Schüssel.
Es ist wirklich superschnell.
Also wenn ich einmal schnell etwas backen will,
sind Muffins eigentlich immer so die beste Antwort darauf.
[Musik]
Dann verrühre ich hier in der Schüssel die Eier mit dem Vanilleextrakt,
gebe etwas Orangensaft dazu
- ihr könnt auch Milch oder wieder Mineralwasser verwenden-,
das Öl.
Das Öl brauche ich komplett.
Beim Saft schaue ich einfach, wie viel ich brauche.
Perfekt.
Und dann einfach beides vermischen.
So schnell geht das.
Jetzt merke ich schon: Okay, ein bisschen fest ist der Teig.
Also nehme ich doch noch den Orangensaft.
Ich muss sagen, der riecht schon richtig gut,
wegen Orangensaft und Vanille,
wie Fanta Cupcakes, nur eben ohne Fanta.
Also praktisch aus 100 % Orangensaft.
Aber der Samira werde ich es als Fanta Donuts verkaufen.
Da freut sie sich.
Die Farbe ist ja dadurch auch echt cool.
Wie gesagt, mit Donut-Backform, diese kurz einfetten.
[Spraygeräusche]
Dann den Teig einfüllen,
entweder mit einem Spritzbeutel oder so direkt.
Die Form einfach fast bis unter den Rand füllen,
also ein bisschen auslassen, so 2-3 mm.
[Musik]
Ruckzuck vorbereitet! [Lacht]
Josh, aus dem Rest mache ich dir einen Tassenkuchen.
JOSH: Oh nice!
SALLY: Wenn meine Mikrowelle jetzt nicht belegt wäre,
hätte ich es einfach in der Mikrowelle gebacken.
So 3-Minuten Tassenkuchen.
JOSH: Gibt's das? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Also jetzt nicht in der Emaille-Tasse,
weil die nicht mikrowellenfähig ist,
aber in der Porzellantasse - yes!
Aber das backe ich dir im Ofen, okay?
Magst du noch Streusel oder sowas drauf?
Kann man noch irgendwie ein bisschen Nougat reinmachen?
Na klar!
Komm, ich hole Nougat aus dem Kühlschrank und Streusel
und dann kriegst du… Wuhuu.
So eine liebe Sally!
JOSH: Das nenne ich Luxus! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Luxus Kameramann!
Luxuskamera live.
So.
[Musik]
Ich warte noch 1 Min. und dann packe ich es da mit rein.
Jetzt bin ich hier soweit, also die Tortenböden sind gebacken.
Ich hab sie abkühlen lassen
und dann auch noch einmal in Kühlschrank gestellt,
damit ich sie gleich gut schneiden kann. Die Donuts sind auch fertig.
Ich finde, die sehen echt perfekt aus.
Josh's Tassenkuchen mit Nougat ist auch fertig.
Den kannst du gleich probieren.
Jetzt wird eine Buttercreme hergestellt,
weil ich später einen Drip machen will.
Da sind Buttercremes generell besser geeignet,
weil die Buttercreme schön fest wird, der Drip gut runterlaufen kann.
Entweder könnt ihr jetzt eine Buttercreme von meinem Kanal zubereiten:
Swiss Meringue Buttercreme, deutsche Buttercreme,
französische Buttercreme, italienische Buttercreme
- was ihr möchtet.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe heute echt wenig Zeit und…
dadurch, dass ich mit den Donuts noch viel Arbeit vor mir habe…
Ich mache die Buttercreme und die schmeckt echt sehr, sehr lecker.
Also ich habe die Buttercreme zum Anrühren.
Da nehme ich hier das Päckchen.
Ich hab auch schon weiche Butter.
Da ist es jetzt nur so:
Hier in eine Schüssel geben, mit Wasser vermischen
und dann erst einmal 30 Min. stehen lassen.
Ich muss auch sagen, bei der hab ich kein schlechtes Gewissen,
weil es superschnell geht und es auch mal etwas Einfaches sein darf.
Es sieht jetzt gleich ein bisschen aus wie Kleister.
Das ist aber völlig normal
und geschmacklich könnt ihr sie gern noch verfeinern.
So schmeckt es jetzt erst einmal nach Vanille.
Ich könnte jetzt hier auch noch Aromen mit dazugeben,
wie Zitronenschalenabrieb, Orangenabrieb oder was auch immer.
Ihr könnt auch ein Fruchtpüree mit einarbeiten,
eins, das richtig gut eingekocht ist.
Das lasse ich jetzt hier einfach einmal stehen.
Ich werde es später nämlich mit Lebensmittelfarben einfärben
und kümmere mich jetzt erst einmal um die Donuts.
Damit geht es dann später weiter.
Für die Donuts, also die Glasur
mache ich jetzt einfach eine weiße Ganache.
Man kann auch eine Zuckerglasur zubereiten.
- aus Puderzucker und Zitronensaft oder Puderzucker und Wasser.
Aber ich glaube, eine Ganache ist hier in dem Fall echt ganz gut.
Ich glaube, das sieht gut aus.
Also habe ich jetzt hier Sahne und Schokolade,
[Musik]
kann die Sahne in einem Topf aufkochen
und dann die Schokolade kurz einrühren.
Dann werde ich die Ganache aber noch einfärben.
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob rosa, blau oder mint.
Deswegen werde ich ein paar hellrosa und paar bläulich-mint machen
und hier noch einmal die Konfettistreusel drauf benutzen.
Ja. So ganz hab ich es in meinem Kopf nämlich noch nicht, wie sie aussieht.
Das ist schon so eine Mint-Torte, weißer Drip und dann die Donuts.
Mal gucken.
Dann ausschalten.
[Musik]
Jetzt ein bisschen Lebensmittelfarbpaste dazu.
Hier muss ich jetzt sagen, das ist jetzt nicht ganz rosa,
sondern eher Lachs - durch die weiße Schokolade.
Die ist nämlich nicht weiß, sondern eher gelblich, wie ihr sehen könnt
- das ist bei Ganache immer so.
Ich gebe es ja einfach noch ein bisschen weiße Farbpaste dazu,
damit ich diesen Gelbstich heraus bekomme.
Müsste ihr nicht machen,
aber für mich ergibt das optisch jetzt schon Sinn.
Jetzt kann ich die Donuts reintauchen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das gleich aussehen wird, aber ich hoffe gut.
Da hat sich eine Luftblase gebildet.
[Musik]
Das ist schon schön, aber ich kann sie tiefer tauchen.
Die schönen Donuts hab ich jetzt im Kühlschrank.
mache jetzt hier die Buttercreme weiter.
Wie gesagt, es sieht ein bisschen aus wie Kleister,
aber es schmeckt gleich sehr gut
und die Buttercreme wird auch sehr gut.
Das jetzt hier einfach mit der weichen Butter schön cremig rühren.
Auch hier gebe ich ein bisschen Farbpaste dazu,
damit es so eine mintfarbene Buttercreme wird.
Aber das mache ich erst, wenn die Torte gefüllt ist.
Innen lasse ich sie, glaube ich, hell und außen mint.
Ich überleg es mir gleich. Ich rühre jetzt erst einmal.
[Musik]
Als Nächstes kann ich jetzt hier die Tortenböden herauslösen.
Das geht am besten mit so einem Tortenringmesser,
mit einem Backformmesser.
[Musik]
Dann stürze ich die Böden hier raus
und kann sie einfach mit der Tortensäge durchschneiden
- schöne, dünne Böden.
[Musik]
Jetzt wird die Torte gefüllt.
Wie gesagt, nehme ich hier jetzt eine Marmelade.
Ich habe hier einfach so eine gemischte aus Erdbeere, Himbeere, Aprikose;
habe so alle Marmeladenreste, die ich gefunden habe, zusammengemischt.
Das ist auch immer ganz gut, weil man so alle Reste im Kühlschrank ein bisschen
verbrauchen kann. Und wird jetzt hier im Wechsel mit der Buttercreme
die Torte einfach schön gefüllt und anschließend gekühlt.
Danach kann ich sie dann außen glatt streichen.
Ich achte immer darauf, dass ich die Creme schön glatt streiche,
also keinen Hubbel, denn wenn ihr jetzt einen Hubbel formt,
wird natürlich der nächste Boden auch nicht glatt.
Also immer schön gerade.
[Musik]
Guckt mal:
Den obersten Boden, also diesen Hubbel, lege ich meist so rum drauf,
damit ich einfach immer schön gerade weitermachen kann.
Den Abschluss bildet dann noch einmal dieser flache Boden.
Dann ist es noch schöne, hohe Torte.
[Musik]
Den Rand glätte ich jetzt einmal kurz mit einer Teigkarte.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Torte so einfach in den Kühlschrank stellen.
Ich werde sie allerdings einmal mit Folie kurz einpacken.
Die kann ich wieder benutzen.
Und mit dem hohen Tortenring,
damit sie einfach ein bisschen an Stabilität gewinnt.
Es wird aber auch so gehen.
Nur so bekommt sie schon einmal gleich
eine richtige, perfekte runde Form.
Zack.
Sobald sie gekühlt ist, geht's damit direkt weiter
und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit aufräumen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Torte
- die ist jetzt perfekt gekühlt -
komplett glatt streichen.
D.h., ich nehme hier die restliche Buttercreme.
Die habe ich übrigens bei Raumtemperatur gelagert,
also nicht im Kühlschrank.
Dann streiche ich die hier an den Rand.
Dann zuerst den Rand glatt ziehen und dann auch noch die Oberfläche.
[Musik]
Diese untere Schicht hab ich jetzt hell.
Da kommt jetzt praktisch die mintfarbene Schicht drüber
Und ich werde es doch schon ein bisschen durchschimmern lassen,
so im Naked-Stil, denn ich habe gerade überlegt,
die Buttercreme wird sonst knapp,
aber doch, ich mache es im Naked-Stil,
also jetzt hier oben noch kurz glatt streichen, kühl stellen,
die Creme noch einfärben und dann Naked-Stil,
also nicht komplett deckend, sondern wirklich so,
dass die Böden noch ein bisschen durchschimmern dürfen.
Ich glaube, das fände ich bei dieser Torte schön.
[Musik]
Jetzt wird die Torte kurz eingefroren,
damit die weiße Creme fest wird
und sich dann mit der Mintfarbe nicht vermischt.
[Musik]
Ich muss sagen, dass mir die Torte so richtig gut gefällt.
Also ich glaube, ich glätte sie heute echt nicht.
Ich mache auch wahrscheinlich keinen Drip dran.
Ich gebe sie jetzt erstmal in Kühlschrank,
gucke mir noch einmal die Donuts an und überlege mir noch eine Deko.
Ich mache heute eine unperfekt perfekt Torte im Naked-Stil.
[Musik]
Ich werde jetzt noch Folgendes machen:
Ich hab hier weiße Schokolade geschmolzen, ganz wenig
und werde jetzt die Donuts auf Lollysticks aufspießen,
damit man sie so von der Hand essen kann
und ich sie so auch als Deko in die Torte stecken kann.
D.h., hier einmal reinspießen.
Aber ich sage dir gleich…
Weißt du was, kannst du mir die vorbereiten
und ich mache sie in die Donuts rein? Ja?
Warte, warte, warte, warte.
Guck mal, du machst du so fertig
und ich pack sie in die Donuts rein,
denn die Donuts sollte man jetzt möglichst wenig anfassen.
So ist gut.
ELA: Mama, wie wäre es, wenn wir beide…
SALLY: Möglichst wenig anfassen…
Nein, warte, denn sonst beschädigen wir die Oberfläche.
ELA: Darf ich jetzt ein Donut probieren? [Sally verneint]
SALLY: Ela Mäuschen…
ELA: Was ist?
SALLY: Nicht "Was ist"!
ELA: Mit Teamarbeit kriegt man das schneller hin.
Ja, das ist wahr
und du hast da auch recht,
aber du kannst mir die ja vorbereiten.
Teamarbeit bedeutet, du bereitest es vor.
Eins machen wir auch kürzer für vorne.
Das reicht jetzt erst einmal.
Die anderen Donuts möchte ich nämlich erst fotografieren
und danach aufspießen.
Okay, das lassen wir kurz fest werden
und ich kann schon einmal meine Torte auf eine Tortenplatte setzen.
Deine Abla (große Schwester auf Türkisch) wird morgen 10.
[Musik]
ELA: Psst!
SALLY: Gefällt sie dir?
Du Süße! Möchtest du mal kosten, ob die Torten denn überhaupt gut ist?
Ja? [Ela bejaht]
Die Spitze! [Lacht]
ELA: Mmh!
Gut?
Okay, jetzt ganz vorsichtig hier rüber.
Ist die Torte in der Mitte, Ela? Ja, oder? [Ela stimmt zu]
ELA: Langsam, langsam!
Gut machst du das! Jaa!
SALLY: Geschafft! Danke!
Du bist so eine gute Motivation für mich.
Du kleine Maus.
So, dann hab ich mir gedacht,
bisschen Konfetti so an den Rand.
Oh!
ELA: Nein, ich habe mir gedacht… Mal so…
[Musik]
Darf ich jetzt ein Donut probieren? [Sally verneint]
SALLY: Dann nehmen wir…
Vorsicht, jetzt nicht drücken; nur an dran heben!
Was wir jetzt noch nehmen, sind die Ziffern.
Eine 10 besteht aus einer
ELA: 1 und einer 0.
SALLY: Ja, und wie alt bist du?
ELA: Eine ganze Handvoll.
SALLY: Boah! Und die Samira?
ELA: Ehm, zwei ganze Hände.
SALLY: D.h., du bist genau halb so alt wie Samira? [Ela bejaht]
Cool.
Warte, warte. Stopp!
Guck mal, wir machen das so…
Also wir drehen es einmal zu uns, genau.
Machen wir es so in die Mitte?
ELA: Warte! Wie wäre es… Wir machen das… Warte, ich zeige dir das!
SALLY: Oder wir machen das hier…
ELA: Ja, so.
So ist es gut? [Ela bejaht]
SALLY: Wir können es ja einmal so machen
Dann können wir immer noch überlegen,
wie tief wird es dann gleich versenken, okay?
Also dann warten wir einfach, bis die Donuts fertig sind
und stecken das noch drauf und dann ist die Torte fertig.
[Musik]
Also dann habe ich jetzt hier noch diese Wimpelkette gemacht.
Muss ich mal gucken, wo ich sie platziere - so?
ELA: Vorne dran. Können wir das so machen?
SALLY: Nein, weil ich gern die 10 vorne hätte
und jetzt packen wir praktisch diese Donuts dahin.
[Musik]
ELA: Darf ich jetzt ein Donut probieren?
SALLY: Was willst du?
[Mit lauterer Stimme] Ein Donut probieren!
[Mit nachgemachter Stimme] Was?
ELA: [Mit lauterer Stimme] Ein Donut probieren!
SALLY: Warum?
ELA: Weil ich mal kosten möchte.
[Sally lacht]
[Musik]
Cool, dann kann ich damit Schnipp Schnapp spielen.
Schnipp Schnapp, Haare ab.
SALLY: Nein, kein "Schnipp Schnapp, Haare ab."
Das haben wir jetzt schon oft genug hinter uns.
JOSH: Zeig mal her!
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Die kleinen Fädchen mache ich noch weg,
aber so ist jetzt Samira Überraschungstorte fertig.
Und sie hat sich ja eine Candy-Torte gewünscht.
Sie liebt Donuts und ich glaube…
Ich meine, gut, Candy hab ich jetzt nicht drauf,
aber ich glaube, eine Donut-Torte ist ihr auch nicht eingefallen.
Ich hoffe, sie freut sich morgen. Mein kleines Baby wird schon 10.
Ich denke mir dann immer so:
Krass. Wenn sie das in 10 Jahren anschaut,
dann ist sie 20
und Ela dann 15,
so voll Teenager.
Und ich so 29. [Lacht]
Oh man, die Zeit vergeht so schnell.
Und wisst ihr, was ich cool finde?
Ich meine, ich hab ja schon…
Ich kann das jetzt an der Stelle sagen.
Ich habe schon manchmal überlegt:
Wenn ich am Anfang gewusst hätte, wie groß der Kanal mal wird
und diese Bekanntheit größer wird, weiß ich nicht,
ob ich damals so die Kids mit reingenommen hätte.
Aber es ist halt einfach so passiert,
weil ich aus der Küche raus einfach gekocht und gebacken habe
und Samira hat so mitgemacht.
und Ela ist so reingeboren und reingewachsen.
Heut denke ich mir so…
Ich meine, wir laden ja echt nur schöne Dinge hoch,
wie sie hier naschen und mitbacken.
Wenn ich mir jetzt alte Videos angucke
und gucke, wie klein die Samira war,
so 2, als sie das erste Mal
- oder eineinhalb oder… ja, eineinhalb war sie,
als ich das erste Mal Videos gedreht habe.
Da war sie so mini und jetzt wird sie einfach schon 10.
und sie kann so ihren ganzen Prozess einfach in den Videos sehen.
Dann weiß sie irgendwann:
"Ja, meine Mama hat immer mit mir gekocht und gebacken
und gebastelt und gebaut
und mir eine Kinderkirche gekauft
und ich durfte bei meiner Mama immer Donuts naschen",
denkt sich dann die Ela.
Bevor es jetzt noch sentimentaler wird, sage ich:
Auf Wiedersehen!
Also die Torte ist wirklich eine Torte,
die ihr an einem Tag super schafft.
Mit ein bisschen Kühlzeit
und dann wirklich jemanden toll überraschen könnt.
Also Happy Birthday, mein kleiner Schatz.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss!
Ela, ihr seid schon zu groß.
ELA: Mami, darf ich gleich einen Donut probieren?
SALLY: Natürlich, damit wir für morgen schon einmal vorkosten können,
ob es wirklich gut schmeckt.
Guck mal, jetzt überleg mal!
Die Samira sieht noch irgendwann das Video.
Möchtest du deiner Schwester
was ganz, ganz Nettes zum Geburtstag wünschen?
Dann sprich es mal zum Josh in die Kamera.
ELA: An meiner Stelle würde ich dir schenken…
ähm, Acrylfarben schenken.
SALLY: Was wünschst du ihr? Dass sie immer glücklich ist oder… [Ela stimmt zu]
Ja? Und immer gesund… [Ela stimmt zu]
Und willst du ihr vielleicht sagen, was du für sie empfindest?
ELA: Ja.
SALLY: Was?
Ob du deine Schwester magst oder liebst oder gar nicht magst?
ELA: Du malst toll!
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Magst du nicht sagen:
Ablacığım, ich liebe dich.
ELA: Also deine Kunst finde ich ganz schön!
SALLY: Samira, ich liebe dich.
Und liebst du sie?
ELA: Ja.
SALLY: Ja! Über alles, deine Schwester?
Sehr schön.
Oh, mein Schatz.
Deine Schwester und du.
ELA: Mama, guck mal…
SALLY: Du Quatschkopf. Du kleiner Quatschkopf.
ELA: Tschüssi!
SALLY: Komm, wir helfen Sarah bei den Fotos.
Wuhuu.
[Musik]
Okay Samira, also…
Jetzt darfst du die Augen öffnen.
[Alle singen "Happy Birthday to You"]
[Murat klatscht]
[Musik]
Komm, jetzt wünsch' dir was und puste die Kerzen aus!
[Alle singen "Happy Birthday to You"]
Jetzt darfst du 10 Kerzen auspusten.
ELA: Auf einmal.
SAMIRA: Denkst du, ich schaffe alle?
SALLY: Ich glaub schon!
Nicht zu stark! Nicht zu stark.
Und los!
Juhu! [Beifall aus dem Hintergrund]
[Musik]